[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance perhaps the most crucial
break in Trump's Russia scandals comes
to us fresh from the pages of The Strand
Magazine and its new issue for December
1892 inspector Gregory if Scotland Yard
asks Sherlock Holmes is there any other
point to which you would wish to draw my
attention Holmes replies to the Curious
Incident of the dog in the night-time
Gregory states flatly the dog did
nothing in the nighttime Holmes
concludes that was the Curious Incident
publicly publicly the attorney for
General Michael Flynn agent of the
Turkish government Russian television
contributor and not briefly enough
national security advisor in this
shambles of a presidency publicly
Flynn's attorney volunteered Flynn to
testify to the Intelligence Committee of
the Senate or the House or both and
confirmed discussions about testifying
and even revealed he might not be asking
for full immunity for his client and by
the following morning things were not
looking promising for he or Flynn first
a senior congressional official said off
the record that the Senate committee
viewed Flynn's bid as wildly preliminary
and that immunity was not on the table
and a second source added at this time
by the next morning the ranking Democrat
on the House Intelligence Committee Adam
Schiff in essence said too soon then
after Trump's crazy tweet suggesting
Flynn should seek immunity from what
Trump wants us to believe is a fake news
which punch ship added everybody should
meet Flynn's offer with skepticism but
the headline here is not so much Flynn's
offer but rather the reaction to it from
both of the intelligence committees in
short the dog did nothing in the
nighttime and that was the Curious
Incident because other similar dogs in
other similar night times have barked
the house down in 1973 as the unraveling
of the Watergate cover-up began to
accelerate white house counsel John Dean
realized he was being set up as the
scapegoat
President Nixon asked him to write a
report summarizing everything Dean knew
about that scandal Dean then as now no
dummy
quickly figured out that Nixon could use
that document as a shield and say the
report was the first time
he had heard these details but he could
also use it as a spear against Dean by
noting it was kind of odd that Dean knew
all this stuff when he Nixon did not
Dean knew he needed to make a deal with
somebody
his lawyer initially approached federal
prosecutors with Dean's offer to testify
in exchange for immunity testify not
against the president but against his
immediate supervisors as Dean's attorney
at the time Charles trapper colorfully
quoted Dean we can't talk about the P
the feds thought about it and turned him
down and then Nixon fired Dean Dean's
lawyer then went to the new committee
the Senate had formed to investigate
Watergate which also had the right to
request immunity for its witnesses when
Dean said that he was now ready to talk
about the P Dean got his immunity he got
it immediately he also got something
else immediately he went right into the
federal witness protection program they
moved him out of his home they moved him
to another state the day two months
later when the Senate committee found a
witness willing to confirm Dean's
suspicion that Nixon had secretly taped
all the conversations in the Oval Office
committee counsel Sam - had to get Dean
to come back from a secure undisclosed
location to Washington just to tell him
and get his reaction to that starting in
the spring of 1973 John Dean spent a
total of 540 days as a protected witness
those dogs didn't just bark the house
down they barked the White House down
but Flynn's offer didn't get as much as
a tail wag I had breakfast with John
Dean last Saturday morning I've known
him for nearly 20 years and consider him
both a friend and a true American Hero
happily we had so much to talk about
that Michael Flynn barely took up five
minutes but as usual John made the most
of those five minutes yes the obvious
reaction to flames offered to make a
deal is the suspicions voiced by Adam
Schiff and reinforced by this child
Trump's tweet his lawyer may have
offered nothing and demanded everything
less obviously these unusually public
comments by the attorney and by
congressman Schiff could be opening
gambits each man staking his ground for
a battle to come over what flynn
testifies to and what he gets for it
except that Flynn's lawyer is named
Robert Keller and his bachelor's degree
was in politics and Russian Studies
and he wrote his thesis on the black
sheep of the Russian Revolution Trotsky
and he was a never Trumper and last june
he tweeted quote spy novel script russia
hacks DNC for Donald Trump Oppo Trump
says nice things about Putin hmm and
three weeks before the election Keller
blasted Trump for claiming the voting
was rigged and Kellner said quote the
only real threat to this election is the
reported effort by Russian intelligence
services to hack election systems which
is something that Trump himself has
failed to condemn not only does that not
sound like a lawyer offering nothing and
demanding everything but Keller's letter
sounds like he's not asking for
everything it ends if you will recall no
reasonable person who has the benefit of
advice from counsel would submit to
questioning in such a highly politicized
witch-hunt environment without
assurances against unfair prosecution
unfair not assurances against
prosecution assurances against unfair
prosecution john dean reminded me that
even he didn't get blanket immunity and
did not ask for it he got use immunity
they can't use what you say while
testifying against you but everything
else you've done is still fair game
so Quinn's offered to testify is made by
an anti-trump Russian conspiracy
affirming student of Russian history
whose law firm biography identifies his
areas of expertise as including federal
and state campaign finance lobbying
Disclosure pay-to-play
and government ethics law the federal
election campaign Act lobbying
Disclosure Act ethics and government Act
foreign agents Registration Act and
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act in short
it sounds like mr. Keller was born
specifically to represent Michael Flynn
and the Senate and House intelligence
committees aren't climbing over each
other to make a deal with Flynn and his
anti-trump lawyer John Dean smiled it
may be very simple he said you immunize
somebody to get him to testify against
somebody bigger Flynn would not be given
any kind of immunity testify against
Paul Manafort or Carter Paige probably
not even to testify against Jared
Kushner
only person bigger than Flynn in this
scandal is Donald Trump so why wouldn't
they jump at a chance to get a witness
to testify against Donald Trump even if
they had to let Flynn get away with
whatever he allegedly did the likeliest
reason they don't need him to make the
case against Donald Trump they don't
need anybody to make the case against
Donald Trump they may have made the case
against Donald Trump already turns out
the dog may not be doing nothing in the
nighttime the dog may be reading through
all the transcripts and listening to all
the recordings of the Russian diplomat
that American intel has reportedly
identified as a Russian spy the same one
the steel dossier charged with
supervising putin's efforts here to get
trump elected that it may also turn out
that the witness vital to convict donald
trump is actually donald trump resist
peace